Elon Musk the world's richest man is
poised to be the new owner of Twitter
and of course it's starting off with a
bang yesterday he went and visited the
Twitter headquarters and he walked in
with a sink and then he tweeted out let
that sink in the billionaire meme Lord
is at it again but he went into the
building and he met with employees for
hours and talked to him about what his
vision was what he thought they needed
to do better and how exactly he thought
that Twitter could improve itself now of
course that isn't the only thing he's
got to do in terms of managing the
internal employees on top of that Elon
posted a brand new statement to Twitter
advertisers stating that he believed
that Twitter was important for Humanity
that he wanted to create a digital Town
Square where conversation was encouraged
as long as it didn't incite violence and
that he thought that advertising could
actually be seen as content not as spam
when it's done right Elon Musk also is
doing all of this in the face of plenty
of people scrutinizing him first you
have the mainstream media and many
people who are talking heads in the Tech
Community they think Elon crazy they
think that Elon doesn't know what he's
doing but Elon seems to have done pretty
well in his career so far Additionally
you also have Twitter employees tweeting
at him basically trolling him taunting
him who do you think elon's gonna fire
first probably the people who are
talking on the internet at the end
of the day Elon Musk understands how to
build great teams with great talent he
understands how to keep them maniacally
focused on exactly what the mission is
and then he understands how to drive
incredible Effectiveness and efficiency
across at these teams Elon Musk is the
new owner of Twitter gives a lot of
people hope he's likely to encourage and
Protect free speech he's likely to
drastically improve the product in ways
that we can't even imagine yet and also
he's likely to get rid of all of the
people who end up getting in the way of
the mission of that company these are
companies and we live in a country of
capitalism ultimately their purpose and
their legal responsibility to their
shareholders is to make a profit Elon
Musk is one of the greatest entrepreneur
renewers of our lifetime he's a
fantastic leader and he continues to
defy the odds of all of the naysayers
Elon Musk is now the brand new owner of
Twitter and something tells me there may
be a lot of changes on the horizon but I
don't think that those changes are going
to be for the worst